[Music]
hello and where are you just whispering
yes II know it is me but if the cats
become a problem he should lock them out
I'm sorry hello and welcome to dear Hank
and John or as I prefer to call it peer
mayaman Hank it's a comedy podcast where
me and my brother John but occasionally
guest guest hosts like this this week's
Mayim Bialik answer your questions give
you dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon maíam did you bring AFC
Wimbledon news you know I did and it's
big it's big it's I'm actually I looked
up some and I was like Oh John's gonna
be sad he missed this week how are you
oh yeah well I'm okay but you know AFC
Wimbledon is really in goalkeeper shock
don't tell anyone yet we have to save it
for the end of the pod okay I'm doing
okay good good how where where are you
at
I'm in my children's room and I'm I'm in
Los Angeles
why are you it is no there's there's no
studio to be had here
it's the the quietest room in the house
as it were because my children are not
here right yes I would imagine that it's
not usually the quietest room in the
house no no I have a child now the last
time I talked I did not that's right
good motions again no I do and he's he's
he's sleeping inside right now and thus
does not need me so that's that's what
I've heard is that if a child is
sleeping you can just leave right and go
somewhere oh yeah is that oh they got
that they figured that out
perfect yeah thanks this is excellent
Parenthood advice I have I have a parent
in question for you okay am I gonna be
okay
you couldn't be okay you will be you'll
be okay in about four years okay all
right well good least there's a horizon
I appreciate ya I appreciate the
perspective yeah well it is it's an
absolute pleasure to have you here I've
you know it's it's very interesting to
hear your voice I
zooom that people know some things about
you but you obviously are on some TV
shows and have been for a long time
right and and also you are just sort of
I don't know like a professional helpful
nerd person on the Internet
is that right um I guess I mean I I
definitely have made a sort of an active
decision to to find an audience that
understands me as I am
since being an actor means having people
like you for what they want you to be
and then I started a website called grap
nation and I've started entering the
YouTube space honestly completely
inspired by you and your brother to try
and make an impact in positive ways that
are helpful and entertaining and don't
necessarily rely on a casting director
telling you that you're good enough yeah
that's that's I I have done a little bit
of the LA thing and I've I don't I don't
really know why anyone would give up
what I do for that just because it's oh
it's a it's rough it's rough it's rough
and it's not like I work in the coal
mines rough but it is a it is a
psychologically and spiritually
challenging environment to to exist in
and you know I was in the industry as a
as a child and I left for twelve years
and got my undergraduate and graduate
degree I had two kids and I've returned
and the Big Bang Theory is a very big
blessing in my life but it was not what
I thought my life would look like so
there's a lot of adjustment going on in
general as there is for all of us feel
that well speaking of psychological
challenges we have a question oh no wait
you have a short poem for us I do I have
a stanza of a longer poem but yes okay
okay just like go at it do it okay so
this is this is a medieval poet he was
born in the middle of the 12th century
his name is pear Vidal and when I read
this this particular poem and this
stanza it reminded me of one of my
favorite musicians Morrissey and you
will see from the from the final line
why that is so this is translated by
Paul Blackburn lady when I was within
your hall
it seemed st. Julien must have been my
host God
ever made such a perfect day as you
formed of that day with your hand in
your making he made no mistake such arms
were cast only to kill me sure I trust
your excellence is too good a thing but
even if you killed me it would be my
honour and if I died I could only die
praising and rejoicing hmm the Martha
the Morrissey lyric to die by your side
is such a heavenly way to die is what I
thought of when I read that medieval
poem yeah things have not changed
exactly I mean things have changed but
but as far as like overly saccharine
love poetry we're still going at it oh
yeah in terms of in terms of painful
love not much has changed in the last
you know eight hundred years or so well
in terms of painful love or in this case
painful non love this question comes at
us from Lindsey who asks dear Hank and
maíam I recently asked one of my friends
to prom she's a year younger than me and
I wanted to carry on my tradition in my
friend circle of bringing underclassmen
to prom a year early so they can
experience it unfortunately she took my
prompt Rosel promposal to mean had a
romantic interest in her which I don't
she has confessed that she likes me too
and I don't know how to deal with this
do I tell her that I'm not interested
and have the most Awkward prom ever
or do I just not break the facade and
let her down later dubious advice is
much appreciated with much uncertainty
Lindsey my you I don't know
I felt like you were gonna have the
answer Maya I have the answer is it my
turn to say it yeah I I'm always going
to advocate for honest and sincere
conversations even if it hurts other
people and it's never too young to start
doing that kindly and lovingly yeah yeah
so how do you do this kindly in love in
lovingly is it sort of like okay here at
Lindsey I asked this question to a
podcast they have answered it and I
would like you to I would like you to
listen to the podcast so that we don't
have to have this awkward conversation
that seems like a good way to do it yeah
I ya know I think that I think that
that's pretty much the way you have to
do it there's no way to soften the blow
of reality in this case and it's going
to hurt her and I think a lot of people
avoid having honest and sincere
conversations because they're trying to
take care of other people's feelings and
I feel like it creates an environment
where no one is able to be honest or
deal with their feelings so this gets to
be the first experience where that's the
conversation it seems that my promposal
fancy word it seems that my promposal
may have introduced a conversation that
is really hard to have but I really want
to go to prom with you
but I'm not romantically interested in
and I hope that we can still go and have
a good time and if you don't want to
I'll understand
yeah and and yeah and I don't know if
there's if there's a good hug that can
come along with it that is an awkward
but it does seem like a moment that
requires a hug
what it's like oh man
I wouldn't want a hug in that situation
[Laughter]
yeah dear Hank and maíam I'm currently
in the middle of getting divorced for
the most part everything is amicable and
we have both moved on with our lives
over this past year we do have a
wonderful three-year-old son together my
ex-husband's birthday is usually the
same week as Father's Day and not really
sure what if anything I should do I
would like my son to be able to give his
dad a gift but I can't just give a
three-year-old cash and send him to the
store should I buy a gift for my
ex-husband or invest time in making a
craft with my son to give him is this my
job at all now that we were separated
should I just assume his new significant
other will take this over as always
dubious advice is appreciated thank you
cat oh I have been in this exact
situation I mean I like this question I
have feelings like it seems like you you
end this amicably and you're still
friends so like oh I don't like ya there
and it's still his birthday and he's
still a part of your life right and I
would say my ex's birthday is not the
same week as Father's Day but there are
other holidays that fall around my ex's
birthday so this is something that has
been in my head
a lot here's here's my thing we get to
teach children how to behave separate
from our relationships and our
resentments or issues the fact that it's
the same week as Father's Day I think
would be really nice to show your child
whether the father has a new life to
show the child this is how we celebrate
dad on Father's Day and his birthday and
you don't need to go over the top I
think the first year after we were
divorced I was like let's buy him a
computer and my therapist is like now
you don't need to buy him a computer but
I think I think making cards having the
child decorate a card is always a nice
thing when I had children that age and I
was just divorced I would have my child
say nice things about daddy like I would
say what's something you like about
daddy and I would sort of transcribe you
know like daddy whatever it gives me
candy or whatever it is and then have
them decorate the card I think that's
nice and if there's something small as a
gesture that the child can participate
in wrapping I think it's important to
show we give important people gifts and
it really is it's it's the ultimate gift
to teach that child that while giving
the ex-husband a gift boom you're really
good at this you are better at advice
than John and green are or sure I feel
like we're dispensing actual good advice
on this episode of dear Hank atonic
super off-brand sorry it turned things
around I'm gonna have hit a question
from Stephen who asks dear Hank and
maíam something that I've been wondering
for years
what is the clothes fastener technology
in Star Wars do they have zippers or
velcro or did all species use the same
pimento in your eyes Stephen in
Cincinnati so I'm gonna let you take
this one first
are you Star Wars fan I can't imagine
you're not a stylist I am I am a Star
Wars fan but did you upon reading this
question go and Google like every
costume designed from all of Star Wars
no no I didn't do prep I don't know if
that's what I was supposed to do know I
didn't do prep I just used my brain like
thought about it yeah I so I did a
little bit of prep and I'll say that
they use it use it they seem to use
everything they seem to have vel
they seem to have even magnetic
fasteners it looks like on a couple of
atoms some some you know those belts
that like that they're like like the
straps on my back packs a couple of
those show up but then you have and you
have buttons all over the place lots of
zippers and things you know just like
but not but unlike normal life I think
there's a lot of hidden zippers yeah
yeah yeah yeah well that's a custom
designed thing in general as like with
like you don't necessarily want it a
zipper puppet like [ __ ] so I think
there's a lot of like the the fabric
goes over where the zipper is because
otherwise there's nobody put that shirt
on so you know this doesn't it just
doesn't look as nice I mean you then you
can't use a Mickey metal zipper Pole
which is what used to be on one of my
favorite jackets I mean I think zipper
pulls are so like we need a solution to
the zipper pull crisis zipper pulls have
gotten so boring
all my hoodies have normal zipper pulls
and they're just like they're from you
know YKK which is the the biggest you
know they make 90% of the zippers in the
world and I think that they're like
there should be a way for me to replace
my YKK zipper pulls with something a
little more interesting and I like what
I just attach things to the zipper is my
solution
you attach so you put something on the
end of the zipper pull yeah so like I
used to have a this is not an
advertisement for Mickey Mouse or Disney
but I used to have a Mickey Mouse they
it would clip on to your zipper so that
you could grab Mickey's face and pull
that up so I took to doing that cuz
that's what people like me do
I would attach like a cute little tie or
something like that and it's easier to
to to then and cuter yeah but I think
that I think the whole the whole
assembly there should be a way to
replace it imal if you can't hear me
well it's because I'm examining my
hoodie zipper right now i I did a bunch
of research on the company that makes
YKK the YKK the company that makes like
every zipper in the world and it's
amazing it's an amazing company I'm like
fascinating history but anyway do that
yourself that's not what that's not what
this podcast is about but I do like I
have had this thought several times in
the last couple of years that like
zipper
I feel like zipper pulls are an
opportunity that we're missing is all
too agreed yeah agreed like
buckles had this for a little while
socks are having it right now where
people are expressing themselves through
their socks in a way they hadn't
previously of course that's true yeah
like enamel pins are happening but I
think that zipper pulls maybe the net
I'm gonna predict right now zipper pulls
are the next big thing in personal
expression for for Ford nerds like us
you heard it here first folks Hank green
fashion expert so yeah I think that this
is a you know obviously this is a galaxy
that's very far away it was a long time
ago but I think that this is a case of
just convergent fastening technology
like it's just gonna happen that these
are the things that work well velcro you
know straps and belts and and zippers
and buttons and magnetic snaps
absolutely all right do you have another
one for us yes and actually if you're
here's a little hint as to which one I'm
gonna ask if you're having a cold you
may want to eat something spicy dear
Hank and my um my boss keeps asking me
things like are you kidding jong-un's
cousin or did you bring dog meat for
lunch
oh god this is obviously a harmless joke
but I hate it is it I'm the only wait
well let's see what the question is okay
I'm the only Asian working in a building
of about 200 white people so when I
first started I cracked some jokes about
being Asian to make everyone feel
comfortable with me but now a year later
my boss is daily racially centered
banter is getting old annoying and at
times mean should I say something to
stop her
I feel like if I do she won't know how
else to communicate with me also I also
I feel like it's kind of my fault for
starting it any advice
kimchi and Vegemite same Oh yo yo first
of all well I guess so I'm understanding
now so you've got so you've got 200
white people in this building your
direct report boss is thinks that thinks
that you know your race is a thing to
comment upon like the color of your of
your shirt
but worse than that way worse than that
I don't like so the thing is this boss
is obviously not the top boss at your
company 200 people you have an HR
department and this is what the HR
department is for when you have a part
like when there's a problem with your
boss that doesn't have anything to do
with your job
that's who you're supposed to talk to
and that is the kind of exact kind of
problem that they want to hear about
because it is a huge like it's big it's
pretty big deal mm-hmm and and also I
think what's really interesting the I
feel like it's kind of my fault for
starting it yeah let's not go down that
road there's no excuse for what's going
on it is not your fault for starting it
unless by starting it you mean being
Asian I mean it's it's interesting that
coming into a place where you are
different there's a there's often
there's often a sort of psychological
desire to be like hey I know I'm aware
that I'm different and here here it is
I'm Asian and here's my joke about how
I'm a different person and like trying
to like a little bit alleviate the
tension of the difference that's there I
I have as right and as a Jewish person
I've absolutely done this I've
absolutely when I'm in a situation where
it is clear that people are either
unfamiliar with Jewish people or have
not had a lot of interaction with Jewish
people there is a little bit of kind of
social ice breaking you do as it were I
mean I would never say like how do you
like my hook-nosed or anything like that
and anything anything that I would say
would would not it would not be
acceptable for that to open the door to
people saying oh are you never gonna buy
lunch or anything like that so yeah yeah
I mean that has a huge difference
between those two things
calling it out and being like I'm aware
that I'm different and then someone else
being like yes you are let Miriam ffice
eyes that every day for the rest of the
time that you work here because that was
fun when you did it
no not not okay and you know a really
really important you know kind of 21st
century realization these kind of things
don't have to be brushed under the rug
anymore you know you know a lot of the a
lot of sort of the explosion of you know
the notion of equality and liberalism a
lot of that sometimes is taken too far
but my feeling is let's err on the side
of being sensitive cautious and miss
Apple oh man
it's it's it's very weird when people
are like oh god I have to do I have to
think about that now and I'm just like
well you know if you want to be an if
you want to be nice like if you want to
be you know if you want to respect other
humans who are different from you sure
so I'm so sorry that it's inconvenient I
guess yeah I have and I'm I deal with
this a lot in my professional life
because I have a science show on YouTube
where people are like all of us of you
know they're familiar with people who
are like them mostly and and and they
are and like the vast majority of
scishow viewers are white dudes and and
they you know it's it's difficult to
understand the experience of other
people and maybe they're not experienced
at it and and when they're like why why
did you talk that way I'm like well
because I have trans friends who are
like it's better like it's it's less
troubling for me when you talk a certain
way when you don't connect biological
sex and gender and I'm like oh okay well
then I won't do that
and then people and then like somebody
who this doesn't affect it all starts
just screaming at me like I have caused
the greatest unjustice in human history
by acknowledging the existence of trans
people and I'm like I don't I don't know
what's where to go from here like why
are you so mad I didn't tell you how to
talk I talked to the way that I thought
was right respectful to the people that
have talked to me about this issue and
yeah totally lost on that
and I wanted to say it out loud because
I've been I've been experiencing it for
the last two years and I didn't really
talk about it until recently and I
started talking about it to the scishow
audience and it has MIT it has been I
feel like better for everybody to have
it a little bit out in the open so
agreed anyhow this question is from
Rachel who asks dear brothers from a
mother with the last name of another
color that's a reference to a song I
wrote a long time ago but unfortunately
it's not applicable in this situation
and less Bialik is a color actually it
is from the root of the word white yes
from the be honest Rock region Russia
Ukraine Poland
hey but we're not yeah unfortunately
unfortunately perfect excellent it
siblings at least Rachel Rachel asks I
was playing a game of french toast
online with friends and that I met at
nerdcon nerdfighteria thanks for that by
the way and we stumbled upon a problem
that is threatening to rip us apart is a
necktie a type of scarf in all caps god
ah I mean I like I don't even want to
look look at the rest of this question I
lives very long
there's the substantial amount of
discussion of what a scarf is that
continues here can we just get beyond
needing to label everything to know what
what things go in what category and
people being like pop-tarts or
sandwiches and I'm like stop it just go
away okay but Rachel wants to know I
want you to tell her maíam is a pop-tart
a sandwich because it's it's basically
two pieces of bread with something in
the middle know that it's what makes it
not a sandwich them like you and me
hugging someone in the middle of us
doesn't make us a sandwich either well
but it's food it's two pieces of bread
no no but this is like the transitive
property of our existence
okay well we're food to someone or some
animal that'd be good a shark to a shark
three people hugging is a sandwich
perfect done it's that shark is gonna
call it a pop-tart it's what they're
gonna grab it so if a pop-tart is not a
sandwich then a necktie is not a scarf
okay my feeling is the fact that the
word tie is in the name of it means it's
not a scarf it's got the word tie that's
like a verb the thing you do with it but
oh god now it now we're in the rabbit
hole cuz you could tie a scarf I've done
it you could do it but it's not called a
scarf time but would I you can also not
wait you can also not it but you cannot
you can you cannot a tie you can wear a
scarf as a hat you can't wear a necktie
as a hat it's not helpful
my mother used to like make me wear
headbands made out of vintage ties it
was like a thing I think I can picture
blossom doing that exactly she also
would give me I would wear neckties like
belts and when I would be like mom I
don't think this is cool she'd be like
Gene Kelly did it that's a true story so
the neck tie a belt is that next
question everything is everything
oh wow okay yes okay well you know what
I think it's up in the air honestly
Rachel I think I think we're not gonna
get there I think that I think that we
there's there comes a point at which
things blend and there is no definite
definition of what a sandwich is or what
a scarf is and we're just gonna have to
accept that there that there are these
areas where there will be disagreement
like some people will say that color is
orange and some people will say that
color is red because it's right between
red and orange and that's just that's
part of life and in your guide also this
is this is gonna vary culturally as well
right look we we have a culture with a
language that has names for ascots and
ties and bowties and scarves and I'm
sure there are other things I don't know
names for that are related to things
that go around your neck but we only
have one word for snow right no you
clearly don't live in Montana we have
lots of births right I stand corrected
oh man well I feel like I asked that
question just to get mad at Rachel but
I'm not really matter Rachel I'm mad at
Rachel for letting this come between her
and her friends like don't let this tear
you apart like you could tear apart a
necktie after tying it right strip it
off just rip the whole controversy apart
and say we share values and we share we
share a connection and we share
experiences and that's what ties us
together not this stupid piece of silk
or other kind of fabric okay you know
question Mary I do I'm really excited
about this one both for you and for me
okay Thomas says dear maíam and Hank I
love this question so much at the time
of writing this I've just arrived at my
favorite place to go and relax my local
library while the library is awesome for
my distress if ocation needs being quiet
peaceful it is currently packed with
shouting babies and their equally loud
mothers on account of it being according
to the website hmm baby time wait wait
for it I'm gonna ask it the way I would
ask it how is this thing if there's one
thing everyone learns about libraries
it's that they're supposed to be quiet
how do you feel about this should baby
time be a thing also should I get
another quiet place during the weekly
shouting match between tiny humans that
seems to be taking place coffee and rage
Thomas Thomas are you single because you
are absolutely the person for me I am a
mother I'm a mother of two children and
this stuff makes me bonkers bonkers
I live in a town that it's very baby for
baby and child friendly and like like
the owners of businesses are aware
that in order to fill out their
clientele they have to appeal to parents
and get them out of the house and get
them going to places and so when in my
pre-baby life like I haven't gotten to
the point where I could even do this yet
because my child sleeps every 30 seconds
and I'd like and we don't want to mess
with it it's just like at this age at
six months they're all like it's always
either a bat like they're just getting
up or they're about to go to sleep
there's like 30 minutes during which you
can do stuff it's very frustrating but
eventually I imagine this will happen
and but before in my pre-baby life I
would show up at a bar and then suddenly
it would be like a person would be on
the stage singing children's music and a
thousand children would be running
around screaming and that it would be
all and I was just like I came to a bar
I came to a bar to do bar things and
suddenly I found myself in up what is
apparently like a bar Gymboree like it's
it like it's as if the McDonald's
playpen Barberie I got got it on with
with an like a regular dive bar in
Missoula Montana that smells like
cigarettes and like in like a century of
beer poured across the floorboards this
is not normal no but it is a thing but
it's good I mean like it's grams like
I'm happy now that like there will be a
future in which I can take my
three-year-old screaming pile of
annoyance so I I literally could
probably do an hour podcast by myself
about this very topic because I think
here's the thing and I live in Los
Angeles which is you know kind of the
the ultimate in accommodating the baby
culture I I think that there's a couple
things that are going on and one of the
things and you know as a person who
advocates for natural birth and I'm a
lactation educator counselor and a lot
of my world kind of revolves around
people honoring the natural rhythms of
babies children I think that there's
this notion that you know life shouldn't
change or can't change and we have all
of these activities and things that you
can do to try and prove to yourself you
know that that life doesn't have
to change just because you have kids so
you know you can take your baby to yoga
and they have movie theaters where they
turn the lights down but not all the way
and encouraged to bring their children
so their children can run around the
theater and you can all go to the movies
with your children still there or
there's a restaurant here and you know
no judgement against people who want to
use it the restaurant has a a separate
back room with hired babysitters and you
drop your children on so you can have a
fancy Beverly Hills lunch while a
stranger watches your children
well-qualified stranger theoretically
sure but then again for me the the
overarching notion here is how can you
get back to your life as soon as
possible and for a lot of people I
understand that's a valuable priority
but as a person who again advocates for
really living in rhythm with the small
mammal that you have ricocheted out of
your body it is also okay to acknowledge
that your life is going to change and
that tension is what makes us human and
it's what makes us able to accommodate
the changes in our body the changes in
our culture it doesn't all have to be
the same so obviously Thomas may have to
find another time he's welcome to gently
tell the head of the library or the HR
department at the library that this
seems an odd choice of a place to do
baby time but I'm the kind of person I
love my kids not so keen on other
people's kids because I can't control
them and I can't control the way people
parent them when I go to grown-up
restaurants with my children I always go
at the earliest reservation time I asked
to be seated quickly i order quickly and
I get out of there because not everyone
has to like being with my children in a
grown-up restaurant and there were about
two years when my ex and I didn't really
go out to restaurants we cooked we
ordered in we had people bring us food
because we didn't feel like it was other
people's responsibility to tolerate us
wanting to feel normal again we made a
decision to have a baby we dealt with it
the way we felt was most appropriate for
society at large and so Thomas I share
your
I absolutely am holding your hand
through this whole thing so I think that
your your arguments here are completely
valid for like the barbary movie theater
restaurant with a with a nursery in the
back kind of situation where people are
like I'd I had children but I but I
don't want to have had children and so I
want to have my normal life how like and
I have a lot of money to spend trying to
pretend for a moment that I just it's
just me and my wife again and and that's
in like and I understand that I I
understand like wanting to like do that
sometimes and like but but but I think
that there's a difference between that
and like what I'm struggling with right
now is like I would like to meet some
people who have six-month-old babies so
that like we can talk about like what
they're doing and and commiserate and be
like you're doing great and and just
like and be like some day our kids made
are gonna go to school together and and
I think that that's the purpose of a
baby time at the library like it's not
like you know it's not like these
parents would be going to the library
they're not going to the library to use
the library while their babies are there
there there's it's like an event for
parents to meet each other and the
libraries are in addition to being
providing the service of you know
available media for you to to acquire
temporarily they're also community
organizing and event spaces and and it
would be nice if we had more different
kinds of community organizing and event
spaces but we kind of just have the
library and libraries would be a useful
thing in the world and since this is a
useful thing like so so if you think
about it that way maybe it's a little
bit causes a little bit less rage than
its providing a service for your
community but I understand and it is
hard to find other quiet places and and
it is and I hope that this doesn't start
happening to like coffee shops like
places where I'll just give me a place
where it can be quiet and we can do our
thing and I think in it I think there
will always be places for for you but
but in short yes Thomas this is a thing
it's a thing it's a thing I have another
question
I am its from Ben who asks dear Hank in
my
I was opening some boxes at work today
and I submit and it one smelled a little
bit like gasoline
i-i-i-i brought the fact that I enjoy
the smell of gasoline with a co-worker
and we began talking about how it does
seem to be a smell that a lot of people
like why is that I understand why
evolution would shape our brains to
enjoy sweet smells because that
indicates like sugar or food I
understand why we might dislike the
smell of rotting meat or poo because it
contains things that could kill us but
why gasoline if you brought gasoline
back to the time when our ancestors
lived at an Africa two million years ago
would they appreciate the smell - like
this is a dangerous thing this is me
talking now why like do not like
gasoline is like it's cancer in a bottle
like do not look if you Huff it you will
die eventually if you drink it you will
die but I think this and it's clearly
not just because Ben thinks it - that
gasoline kind of smells good oh I love
gasoline so I mean I don't know like
it's I I did a little bit of research
there's some some thought that like oh
it's just like it connects you back to
your past and it's like a nostalgia
thing but but there's also some
indication that you like the smell of
gasoline more like you rate it more
highly on the pleasantness scale if you
are currently hungry which makes me
think that since it's similar molecule
to a lot of aromatic molecules that are
the things that give like fruits and
fruits they're like fun smells and good
smells and in this question Ben talks
about sweet smells but there are no you
can't smell sugar so yeah like so there
are smells that are associated with
sweetness because they come along with
sweetness and they tend to be these
aromatic hydrocarbons that benzene which
is like the primary thing in gasoline is
sort of shaped similarly - and so I'm
guessing that like this kind of like
maybe some similarity there you know so
so yeah you know about the brain some
well yeah and I mean I think that you
know I think that for some people like a
lot of sort of you know the gasoline
research out there in terms of why
people like it says that like oh you're
you're you're you're feeling a small
high you're getting a small high even if
it's not a conscious high meaning you're
not consciously processing like whoa
this feels you know whatever that you
are a so
associating it you know on an
unconscious level with some sort of
euphoria I noticed one person when when
answering this question on the interwebs
said like I like gasoline because I
associate it with fun like boats like
jet ski I don't think for me that's it
but I really um you know I I don't think
that I have a death wish but I like any
not like noxious smell I like you know
those magic markers are like the really
thick markers that we used to make
poster boards for science experiments
like right that's just like I don't know
why that's my jam but it is I've never
passed out from it I have two children
one of whom really likes that smell and
he's sort of my mini-me genetically and
the other one who's murdered his dad
genetically does not like the smell so I
will continue to do this experiment I'm
not having any more children but
wouldn't that have been a great
experiment do it well now you are you
are obligated by science to make pop a
few more now yeah it's out it's at work
yes basically whoa we don't know but
apparently it is a common thing I did
like I didn't realize until I read that
question that it wasn't just me like
I've been kind of quiet about it
experiencing shame right I've got I've
got this weird thing about me know this
dangerous thing you love gasoline and
you're proud well let's just throw it in
a perfume then yeah coming coming coming
next year
motocross the scent oh yeah that's uh
that's that's pheromone ik for sure
alright let's let's hit another question
this one's from Liza oh it was my turn
alright no it is and I said I said her
name wrong anyway ok this is kind of
this is a rough one but I really I
really want to ask
Darcy's question dear Hank and maíam i
would like to preface this email by
saying that I am NOT xenophobic or
discriminatory towards religions I just
don't understand the tradition of Islam
of women women covering themselves my
question is this how should I feel about
head scarves and do you feel differently
about hijab zni cobs and burkas to me
they seem oppressive I know
many countries especially in the Middle
East these are used to oppress women as
shown in society and law however I can
appreciate that some people wear them to
respect God but if God made people
perfect and so on why do we need to
cover ourselves like that why don't men
have to cover heads and faces
specifically in Islam but in some
societies women are demonized and even
killed for not wearing a burqa
again not a xenophobe Darcy PS is there
a term that means discriminatory against
religious beliefs as I know I use
xenophobic incorrectly throughout this
email at several questions it is a bunch
of questions and and that and a bunch of
hard questions yes let's tackle them all
or a couple yeah all right well so the
reason that this question is so
interesting to me is that I come from a
religious tradition where women do cover
their heads and also parts of their
bodies that that often men don't have to
cover and so obviously Islam is
different than the religious judaism but
i think one of the main things that sort
of strikes me about people's often
misunderstandings about religion and
also about the restrictions specifically
on women is that you know we we we are
the the interpreters of religious
traditions as human beings and the the
notion that god has passed down ways for
me to cover myself or restrict my
freedoms to me those really need to be
understood in the context of history and
and the anthropology of of parts of the
world where these religions originated
so you know the the the laws that we
impose on ourselves and on other people
are exactly that they are made by humans
and in most cases they're made by men so
the notion that women have been
restricted in islam or even in judaism
the fact is for pretty much all of human
history women have been restricted in a
lot of ways and and part of that is
biology you know as freud told us right
biology is destiny and to some sense
that's true but i think it's important
to realize that our interpretation is
what's important and the way we
understand it in terms of history is
important as well
there
our restrictions for men for example in
religious Judaism in terms of modesty
and how they dress but historically
there have always been differences in
the way men and women are treated now
I'm not saying that burkas is the way to
go for me that doesn't work or the
notion that when girls are you know of
the age that they start their menstrual
cycle that we cover their heads in
religious Judaism head covering is seen
as a change in status from unmarried to
married and that's sort of how I've
grown up framing it
it is very upsetting to see women
completely covered and a lot of women
who claim that they're happy that way
are also growing up and and living in a
culture of religious patriarchy so a lot
of times we don't know things are not
okay until we see more of the world and
understand sort of more of how how
history is is moving forward so I don't
know that there's an easy answer to this
I say though that we shouldn't just
demonize religions because honestly it's
culture in general that has
distinguished men and women because of
their biology and because then of how
culture interprets that but blaming God
is really not the place to go here
because you know God as far as I'm
concerned God's in charge of creating
the world and then we're in charge of of
being the human beings that try and
interpret that and bring meaning to the
world in a way that God cannot
communicate directly with us
I feel tremendously unqualified to to
answer this question and so I'm glad
that you were here today to help with
that like the thing that I generally try
to remember is that we all do things
based on our culture that don't like
that like that we think make perfect
sense but if you think about them they
don't really like it would be very weird
for me to go leave my house in a
sundress and and people would comment
upon that and and as many people would
you know if ITIF I did that in the wrong
place I would be in a lot of trouble
like I would potentially not make it
home unscathed
in America and so we have like like
there are and like but I can also say
that I prefer to not wear sundresses why
is that probably not because I wouldn't
be comfortable in them if I had been
raised wearing sundresses
probably be super down with it I
probably look pretty cute but if like
but the fact that like I have grown up
in a culture where that is the norm like
I would never be like you know like this
is like like we need to restructure my
society too or even force people to
dress a certain way when they have had
their life you know like when they when
they have been told their their whole
life that like you should cover your
head and that is the thing that happens
you know in you know in you know lots of
different traditions for both genders
you know Sikhs for example like in
public always have their heads covered
so like like I did like I get very
weirded out when it's like yes we should
understand that this is a tool of like
of culture and that it isn't like and
that it is a system that you know like
comes out of men trying to control women
or court just or succeeding in
controlling women but at the same time
like I don't like you can't jump in and
tell people that they can't dress a
certain way anymore
because you're trying to free them
because that is the opposite of freeing
them absolutely it's a hard one though
but it is very I think we did well I
think were to separate the idea of of
culture and the idea of religion and
like and and know that there are many
religious people who who do things
differently and many people who feel
very free and very liberated and also
wear headscarves
like and you know I I have I have those
friends and they're like and like it
doesn't even occur to me that they're
headscarf is is like a result of you
know them their their heritage coming
from a patriarchal place because like
all it like first of all all of our
heritage does and like even now it does
but but like they are now you know like
having their experience of their you
know their worldview their religion
their connection their American assault
at inform who they are like it's just
that like they're continuing desire to
have
to you know dress in the way that they
like to dress is a thing and that's dope
all right I am I have I have one more
question before we get to the
all-important is from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon
this one's from Lisa who asks dear Hank
and I am I'm 15 years old and I want to
get a summer job the thing is I have no
idea how to describe myself in a CV I'm
a very awkward and shy person how did
you describe yourself when you were
looking for your first job dubious
devices welcome yours Lisa I'll be
honest
you just walk into Walmart and you're
like I would like to stock your shelves
and they'll be like okay here's $7 an
hour or whatever it is like it's if
you're getting if you're getting that
kind of job they're happy too happy to
give it I actually have a I mean in if I
CV I usually think that means sort of
like an academic resume of like you
don't have to describe yourself in a CV
but I guess maybe she's talking about if
there's like a application it says
describe yourself and she's confused as
to how you describe yeah so I mean I
happen to be an introverted person and
to me I like that term more than awkward
and shy I don't typically say to people
I'm a little bit on the spectrum I
usually say I'm an extrovert and
introvert here are the things that I
excel at some of these things are
challenges for me and I'm very you know
excited / motivated / interested in
being able to find a place at your you
know place where I would like to work
yeah and also I think that it's
important to know that like there are a
lot of things that you aren't going to
be good at because you've never had a
job so you don't you don't exactly know
what people want what like what this job
is and how it works and and what you
will be doing and what's required of you
but I do think that it's like focusing
on strengths obviously as the thing that
you do in in job applications can you
work when you're 15 and be and also
being and also being honest what is that
allowed like when did what is the age
where you can start working clearly 15 I
think 15 in some places yeah 14 minimum
age for employment and specified
occupations outside
hours sixteen basic minimum age for
employment so I don't even know if you
can you got him beat you gotta be
careful Lisa maybe she's maybe she's on
the cusp come on now let's not get
rights from the detail this isn't
cheating a question she's off your
didn't strike we should disguise these
into the right thing by not saying I'm
15 and 3/4 years old because that that
is intolerable so she can't wait with
you
I appreciate Lisa you haven't done it
the way that you've done it because
obviously summer is coming up and you
may be sixteen by then but yeah I I
think I think that I think it's a great
thing to get a job at that age and to
get a little bit of responsibility and
learn what it is to and maybe you know
even become a little less awkward and
shy as you as you connect with folks I'm
not saying like stop being introverted
but you know being able to like like
everything gets better with practice
well and also finding out what you don't
like is often as important as finding
out what you do and a very close friend
of mine who's a very strong introvert
and really really struggles in social
situations you know she actually likes
working in an office filing things
because her actual interaction with
people's minimal she's got the things
that she does she knows how to do them
and she does him on time and she goes
home you know that works for her so you
will also find what works and doesn't
work for you as the person that you are
and the person that you're supposed to
be and the person that you will be
because of course remember that we all
continue to change I I'm 36 years old oh
my gosh I'm gonna be 37 really soon by
the time this podcast comes out I'm
gonna be 37 are you 36 and
three-quarters oh I feel the burn Oh
somebody get a Sal does it smell like
gasoline or burning rubber because I
know you like it oh man oh yeah
this this podcast is brought to you by
sick birds just don't oh don't don't do
it don't don't put yourself in a
situation where mayim Bialik's gonna get
you because she will
says every man I've ever dated this
broadcast has been brought to you by
shark sandwich also known as three
people hugging delicious the delicious
so everything is a sandwich if there's
three things and you've put them next to
each other if you could conceivably
think of a situation in which something
might consume those things it's a
sandwich spod cast is also brought to
you by Mickey Mouse zipper pulls
absolutely adorable on young Mayim
Bialik who is also wearing a necktie as
a belt like Jim Kelly this podcast is
brought to you by child labor laws
helping you figure out how far through a
year you are allowed to apply for a job
in you show up in your like hello on 15
and 3/4 and I would like a job here at
here at Walmart and they'll be like ABS
absolutely absolutely let us begin the
application process well you know it is
time for the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon Dei I have heard
that there is news from AFC Wimbledon
and I want to hear it oh man goalkeeper
shock is what's happening yeah yeah what
is so legend I'm sure fielder has been
let go yeah
so both the goalkeeper so what's the
goalkeeper so so first James Shea is
leaving but now Danny Bowman and chris
Robertson are also leaving Kingsmeadow
oh my gosh I know man you know there are
tough decisions to make and you know
there have been over a hundred
appearances in all competitions for this
club between Bowman and Shea but you
know unfortunately what what Neil Ardley
has said he's the boss he said we've
reached a point where finances and
different things go on and with a heavy
heart we have to let Danny go and over
it it's such a bummer when financing in
different things going and especially
with a player like Danny because they
have such strong allegiances with him
he's never let them down never let them
down
but finances and things
you know have really gotten in the way
people are gonna miss him and he's
really been a step up kind of player his
attitude they say is a model for I mean
he sounds like the perfect guy but as I
said finances and different things oh
that's a bummer I mean John is gonna be
so sad that he wasn't here to deliver
that news it's probably so set up and
he's gonna deliver it again next week oh
yeah but I was so tragic I mean just
shock palpable shock I am pleased that
you were here to give that news because
I think I enjoyed it more than I would
have with John I am I'm still reeling
I'm just reeling well I mean I mean
aren't we all and I'm sure that
everybody out there is listening to the
pod is you know gently weeping into
their into their car steering wheels or
wherever you happen to be drive safe
everyone and don't forget if you put
something in the oven it's probably on
fire by now because we'd get such a good
job of distracting you the news from
Mars is is is good and bad I am in the
next you know like right now we have a 9
operating missions on or around Mars so
we've got we got Rovers we've got got
orbiters that's a lot there's a lot
happening all the same times more than
ever but in 2020 we're gonna have 9 more
missions we're gonna double the number
of missions that are headed to Mars
we've got SpaceX we've got what I lost
it we've got got SpaceX we got the Mars
2020 Rover we got the European Space
Agency's ExoMars mission we've got
China's thing we got the United Arab
Emirates hope orbiter we've got injuries
from India's Mars orbiter 2 so yeah yeah
there's a lot there's a lot happening
and this is great this is very exciting
but we only have a like one way to
communicate between Mars and Earth we've
got this deep space network that NASA
set up and it lets all other you know
space agencies piggyback on it but it
can only handle so much data and you
need a lot of data not just for sending
sending like back pretty pictures and
like spectroscopy stuff
but also like just to figure out like
telemetry and know where everything is
and keep things in the right orbit and
make sure they land in the right place
and keeping them moving around on the
surface of the planet and it's got to
start getting overloaded to the point
where like people are legitimately
concerned about whether we will have too
many Mars missions if they all make it
which we know we're all hoping they do
that we won't have enough bandwidth to
manage the amount of data that we need
just to keep the emissions running not
even including sending back you know
beautiful high-resolution images and
videos so caution to the world we need
we needed more robust deep space network
this sounds like something someone
should have thought about before you and
me right now but your abs alright all
these missions happened really quick
like they're happening faster people are
are designing the missions more quickly
you know SpaceX is like we're gonna land
a lander on Mars in 2020 and you're like
wow it's it's 20 its 2017 you guys like
that's not long from now so we're
getting better at doing it fast and uh
yeah so this is the thing that we needed
to think about and thankfully people are
starting to think about it and I'm sure
it'll you know that's the thing about
NASA like they see problems coming
pretty pretty long way away they're
gonna figure it out I'm hopeful they're
gonna figure it I'm hopeful we're all
we're all hopeful maíam this has been an
absolute joy
you're really good at this oh thank you
I mean I I learned most things I know
from you so thank you oh that's
definitely not the case at least a
mystery that is right sure maybe in
terms of in terms of terms of advice
podcasts but I appreciate you taking the
time out of your day to spend spend time
and if you want to check out mine well
thank you thank you for the thank you
for the faith in me to to allow me to
participate in this this is well if you
want to check out some of the other cool
stuff live is doing her website is gerak
nation gr ok nation and and if you want
to check out more of what's going on
with dear Hank and John you can check
out our patreon at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John we're not doing you
this week in Ryan's because Maya doesn't
have any idea what that is
and I don't want to throw it that deep
into the deep end but there will be
another one next week when John comes
back so we appreciate all of you hanging
out this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
are our producers Rick Victoria bon
giorno is our social media manager the
music is from gunnarolla and I think I
said all the things I usually write it
down beforehand and honestly John mostly
handles this part so I forget how it
goes you can email us your questions and
Hank and John at gmail.com and as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]